E aí
[Música]
se vocês sabiam que a cada 7 minutos uma
pessoa morre vítima de acidente de
trânsito em alguma estrada brasileira e
esses dados são de 2020 da Polícia
Rodoviária Federal ou seja durante esse
Talk temos três mortes anunciadas em
alguma estrada do país e duas delas
poderiam ser evitadas se esses
motoristas estivessem descansados se
eles não estivessem privados de sono
sessenta por cento dos acidentes de
trânsito são causados por fadiga ou sono
do motorista segundo dados da associação
de medicina do tráfego
e esse é um problema mais comum do que
se possa imaginar
cerca de 70 pessoas 70 porcento das
pessoas que vivem em grandes cidades
sofrem com algum problema de distúrbio
do sono Geralmente as que sofrem com
insônia ou excesso de sono na idade do
período Enquanto elas estão no período
fértil depois da menopausa geralmente
essas mulheres começam a ter apneia e os
homens pelo contrário eles tem apneia
depois da andropausa geralmente eles
começam a ter problemas de insônia e eu
convivi com esses dois problemas durante
muitos anos dentro da casa dos meus pais
porque o meu pai era aquele que ganhava
concurso de ronco familiar sabe reunião
de família final de ano final de semana
que junta a família toda e sempre tem
alguém que fala vamos pegar o gravador e
gravar os roncadores para a gente ver
quem que ronca mais alto quem que tem o
ronco mais extenso e meu pai era aquele
que ganhava os concursos de ronco isso é
muito engraçado para quem estava de fora
da situação mas dentro de casa com meu
pai ele sofria com uma sonolência diurna
absurda por conta 10 e dessa apneia toma
remédio para pressão tem problema
cardíaco e isso gerava uma um GAP de
produtividade muito grande por conta
dessa sonolência diurna EA minha mãe por
outro lado acabava tendo problemas com
insônia eu lembro várias vezes a minha
mãe fazendo um guaraná Zinho em pó para
poder se manter acordado e produtiva
Porque ela tinha suas entregas
profissionais para fazer e isso
acarretava acarretou uma série de
problemas né minha mãe no final de
semana acabava tendo jetlag social que
que eu já te levo social você não dorme
bem durante a semana e aí no final de
semana você tenta compensar aquele sono
perdido durante
os dias produtivos da semana e isso
acarretava um forte stress físico e
emocional a ponta da minha mãe quase ter
sido levado embora por um AVC antes dos
60 anos
e é eu não pude ajudar os meus pais
naquela época porque eu não tinha ideia
dos conhecimentos que eu tenho hoje não
fazia ideia do quanto que dormir mal
pode acarretar problemas para saúde mas
hoje eu posso compartilhar um pouquinho
do que eu sei para tentar mudar essa
legião de pessoas que se vangloriam por
dormir pouco e dormir pouco traz muitos
problemas para saúde nos anos 60 dois
jovens rende gartner e makalister
fizeram um experimento para testar quais
as alterações cognitivas que a falta de
sono poderia trazer para uma pessoa e o
Rangel ele foi imortalizado no Guinness
Book Depois de ficar 11 dias e 25
minutos acordados Por que que ele foi
imortalizado né ele foi ele ganhou o
espaço no Guinness né o seu recorde
ganhou o espaço no Guinness e ele foi
imortalizado por que o Guinness viu que
o é que esse experimento poderia trazer
malefícios para a vida das pessoas então
ele parou de registrar esse recorde e
quais foram Então as alterações
identificadas
Paladar olfato audição alteração de
humor e stress Alucinação ele tinha a
língua dele travava ele não conseguirá
repetir algumas coisas depois de um
tempo concentração memória de curto
prazo
irritabilidade paranoia inexpressividade
e depois de um tempo pós experimento ele
começou a sofrer com insônia e algumas
áreas do cérebro dele parecia estar
dormindo enquanto ele estava acordado só
esse mapeamento já é suficiente para
mostrar para qualquer pessoa quanto que
dormir bem é fundamental Mas eu ainda
quero trazer alguns dados que mostram os
benefícios né dorme bem essencial para
saúde
eu não dormi pode matar uma pessoa quem
dorme bem vive cerca de trinta por cento
mais ou seja é fundamental para nossa
longevidade
mantém o equilíbrio corporal interno ou
seja garante a nossa o Meu êxtase sem
contar que dormir bem conserva Nossa
memória some e memória são bidirecionais
se a gente não dorme direito isso
impacta na nossa memória e é fundamental
para o nosso controle emocional e para o
controle do sistema dopaminérgico tem um
caçador de recompensas que a gente tem
Além disso dormir bem é fundamental para
nossa imunidade evitando ganho de peso
estresse depressão hipertensão arritmia
AVC o que que eu trouxe ali o sistema
dopaminérgico
porque quando a gente não dorme bem É
normal a gente procrastinar no dia
seguinte por quê eu tô com amnésia que
ele quer prazer então a gente geralmente
procrastina a gente come comidas mais
Gordurosas mais calóricas que vão dar
aquele prazer imediato né E sem contar
que o nosso sistema de memória sendo
impactado isso impacta o nosso sistema
emocional
Oi e o nosso sistema emocional é o
grande regulador dos nossos
comportamentos
Então se o nosso sistema emocional está
desregulado isso vai desregular a nossa
qualidade comportamental e também
desregula através do sistema nervoso
central todas as nossas respostas
musculares fisiológicas e endócrinas ou
seja
bagunça tudo aí esses dias uma amiga
virou para mim falou assim Carol são
muito fácil de resolver eu tomo remédio
para dormir mas não adianta os remédios
para dormir geralmente eles induzem só o
sono leve e o sono profundo que é o sono
N3 o sono REM que vai garantir a
consolidação da memória que vai garantir
o bem-estar do nosso sistema emocional
eles geralmente não é garantido para o
remédio para dormir sem contar que seu
não eu pego no sono profundo eu acabo
tendo sonolência diurna e sumir traz
dificuldade de atenção e de concentração
uma redução da velocidade do raciocínio
raciocínio vai ficar mais lento e piora
a memória
eu falei de um terço muito importante da
nossa vida que é fundamental Que a Gente
Se dedique a ao sono de qualidade e
agora eu gostaria de trazer para a pauta
um outro texto extremamente importante
da da vida da população em idade
produtiva que a gente se dedica a
próxima nossas atividades profissionais
Eu tenho 15 anos de estrada trabalhando
com empreendedores com lideranças em
todas as regiões do país e eu digo para
vocês por experiência são pouquíssimas
empresas que levam em consideração as
informações sobre bem-estar do Sono para
garantir a qualidade de vida dos seus
funcionários ea a idade dos seus
colaboradores
isso gera um gargalo gigantesco na
economia mundial
existe um dado da academia Americana de
Medicina do sono que mostra que nos
Estados Unidos um trabalhador médio
perde
11,3 dias de trabalho ou
2280 dólares de produtividade por ano
devido à falta de sono isso gera uma
perda anual de 63,2 bilhões para
economia Americana
e tem diagnósticos para mapear o usar
hábitos a qualidade existem pessoas que
vão precisar de medicamentos in que vão
precisar de tratamento médico que vão
precisar passar por exames para detectar
os seus hábitos mas o que que você pode
fazer a partir de hoje para melhorar a
tua qualidade de sono primeiro entender
que nós não somos todos iguais
nem todo mundo se satisfaz ou precisa de
8 horas de sono a meta da população sim
se satisfaz com 8 horas de sono mas
existem os grandes dormidores como eu
que precisam de cerca de 10 horas de
sono e aí vocês imaginam um impacto
Quando Meu filho nasceu eu amamentava
ele queria ser amamentado a cada duas
três horas que eu não tinha tanta
quantidade de leite assim mas os
hormônios da gravidez e aí eu virei uma
bomba-relógio
mas enfim e botando a pauta né Existem
os grandes dormidores como eu que
precisam de cerca de 10 horas de sono
mas também Existem os pequenos
dormidores que se satisfazem com cerca
de 6 horas e a média da população que
dorme 8 horas e se sente bem Como que eu
sei que eu dormi bem Como que eu sei que
eu dormi a quantidade certa para minha
saúde para o meu bem-estar é quando você
dorme 6 8 10 horas de sono e acorda bem
disposto e principalmente sem precisar
de relógio sem precisar de despertador
sem precisar de nenhum artifício Você
consegue acordar sozinho naturalmente e
bem-disposto um outro ponto é levar em
consideração a nossa cronobiologia ou
seja o nosso relógio biológico
existem pessoas que São matutinas Elas
preferem acordar uma das sete horas da
manhã e vão dormir por volta das 22
horas o melhor horário produtivo para
essas pessoas é o período da manhã
existem pessoas que são vespertinas que
preferem acordar por volta das 11 horas
e dormir lá pelas três horas da
madrugada o melhor horário produtivo
para essas pessoas é o período da tarde
e início da noite um funcionário
vespertino O que é contratado por
exemplo para trabalhar numa loja de
shopping até as 10 horas da noite vai
dar 7 horas ele não vai conseguir
atender ninguém mais você vai perder
cerca de três horas produtivas dele um
funcionário vespertino O que é
contratado para bater. As 7 horas da
manhã Provavelmente amanhã dele vai ser
perdida então isso gera um gargalo muito
grande é fundamental a gente prestar
atenção nesses pontos e o quê que pode
ser feito para eu saber quais são os
meus hábitos faça um diário de sono Oi
que horas que você começa a ficar com
sono que horas que você vai para cama
dormir se você tem despertares noturnos
Que horas que você acorda bem e disposto
e para finalizar faça uma rotina de
higiene do Sono evite luz artificial do
celular e da televisão antes da hora de
dormir
evite ficar com a televisão ligada no
quarto reduza as luzes da casa horas
antes do seu melhor horário de sono
evite alimentos hipercalóricos e
gordurosos o ideal é que a sua última
refeição tem o intervalo de duas a três
horas antes de você dormir pense em
coisas boas conserve coisas positivas
porque o sono consolida a memória evite
consumir bebidas alcoólicas e
estimulantes mantém um ambiente
harmônico e se quiser Tome um bom banho
porque ele reduz a temperatura corporal
e ajuda a relaxar
e eu não tenho a pretensão de mudar o
mundo mas se eu tiver despertado a
atenção de ao menos uma pessoa para
melhorar a sua qualidade de vida através
do teu da tua melhora de sono da tua
qualidade de sono eu já terei cumprido
meu papel e vir aqui e aí quem Topa
viver melhor dormindo melhor obrigada a
[Música]
E aí